hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Randy price Randy price is back today
we're checking out another 10 seconds
songs I love this dude he's [ __ ]
awesome he did I did my own version of
bad blood you should just check out the
reaction the version I did is in there
well now we're gonna hear ten second
songs version of Taylor Swift bad blood
featuring Kendrick Lamar let's do this I
love this guy
yeah twenty different cuz baby now we
got bad bud can do we used to be mad
love so take a look there we go oh okay
take it back look where oh man we was on
T like DMC remember that my TLC was
quite ODI team I fancy now POV of you
with nice in Iraq
come right
raids on a time
Oh
makes the Sun better
baby
Oh
you know
Wow
amazing
just for show if you live like that
should look with go if you love like
that blood runs cold
Oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah I want to buy
some merchandise oh god man that guy's
so [ __ ] what's going on everybody
Anthony Vinson the voice of ten second
songs
I just wanted to firstly thank you all
for watching this video and secondly I
just launched a new merch line today you
can find that in the description of this
video or the annotation if you want to
shirt wristbands or guitar picks it's up
to you other than that check out the
other videos on my page subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
follow on my social networks Facebook
Twitter and snapchat at 10 second songs
you spell up at NTEN second songs I'll
see you on Monday for a new video of
announcements and bonus material see you
then [ __ ] love it man so cool he is
so [ __ ] talented please tell me this
mic was on the whole [ __ ] time yet so
was brandy thank God I'm paranoid but oh
man do ten second songs this is really a
me get Alex Ernie I think Ernie you're
[ __ ] kidding me no I don't she look
like a goddamn Ernie to you Oh Ernie
Ernie ball
what's going on everybody Anthony Vinson
the voice of 1070 Vincent's Anthony
Vincent Moneyball is I think a guitar
pick or something we were both not
correct on that other Anthony Vincent
yeah anyway no dudes [ __ ] it you know
what may he's sexy like he's sexy you
know I think that his tongue looks like
a whale pun imagine what that tongue can
do I brought this up in the last video
all right
no not whale tongue but you know what is
just imagine him Anthony
going down on you with that whale tongue
yeah that you want to go home to your
boyfriend tonight huh mm-hmm
gonna think about something else kind of
thought cheat on your boyfriend tonight
mmm anyway you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out brandy prices
channel a lot of fun [ __ ] on there you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine and brandy she has a
little campaign going that I think she
should just say for herself instead of
me
to figure it out go brandy go I
understand the campaign just do it just
do it promote it promote it okay
it's an IndieGoGo campaign for a short
fan film called committed starring the
Joker and Harley Quinn I'm playing
Harley Quinn and it's going to be also
and brandy is actually an amazing
actress ah anyone who's seen her perform
knows this so totally um keep a lookout
for that campaign I'm definitely gonna
contribute so should you
yeah there's lots of cool perks to what
you'll see on that campaign Alex Alvarez
hey Ryan can I have a shout-out I love
you guys Alex Alvarez we love you too
you're special to us you got to
understand Alex when you were brought
into this world you had a twin brother
he is he was the Arnie Arnie and Arnie
was the good-looking one the strong one
the athletic one the one who got great
grades and you're special
cuz you don't have any of that so we
call you special but we love you yeah we
do I sincerely do we're your parents
will love you for as long as you live